♪♪
-Morning, everybody.
Before we get started
with the pitch meeting,
I want to introduce
our new writer, Hannah Horvath.
[ Applause ]
-Hi. That's so nice.
Can I say one thing real fast?
-Um, sure.
-I know I'm new,
and you probably see me
as a threat to your
fragile writers room ecosystem.
But not to worry.
I'm very easygoing
and not at all judgmental,
so just bring on the dick jokes
and the [bleep] jokes
and the [bleep] up meth hooker
with the dildo stuck up
her rusty vagina jokes
because I can hang
in a comedy room.
-Okay. Thank you, Hannah.
-Of course.
I'm just excited to be here
and help you guys get this show
out of its incredible funk.
-Thanks again.
Okay, let's go around the room.
Amber?
-Okay, so what
if we do a segment
called "Seth's Rage Cage,"
and basically, Seth says,
"Hey, winter, it's time
to get into the rage cage."
-All right. It could be good.
Hannah, you're next.
-Okay, this is called
"Would you Masturbate to This?"
And basically what it is,
Seth holds up photos of,
say, Vladimir Putin
or Nancy Pelosi
and asks the audience,
would you masturbate to this?
-Yeah. And then... sorry,
how would the audience respond?
-Oh, they have those button
things like they have on
"Who Wants to Be a Millionaire?"
or they just shout out like,
"Yes, I'd masturbate to this.
I'd masturbate to that."
Whatever they want to say.
-Okay, great. Andrew.
-Um, I have other ideas.
The next one is called
Degrading Fetishes
or Empowering Sexual Acts.
-Okay, Hannah, we actually --
So what we do
is we go one at a time,
and then I'll come back
around to you. Andrew.
-Okay.
-So, this idea is --
-Let's hear what a man has
to say. Great.
-Sorry.
What's that supposed to mean?
-I'm sorry, Seth.
It's just you seem pretty eager
to hear the man's pitch
after completely disregarding
two perfectly great ideas
from women.
-Please do not group
my pitch with yours.
-And I wasn't disregarding you,
it's just Andrew's turn.
-All right, so this is called.
-Oh, my God.
You have literally perfect hair
and it is very black.
-Thank you?
-Can I register a concern
with what I perceive to be
a pretty egregious flaw
in this pitch process?
-Go right ahead.
-My concern is that
before it gets back to me,
someone else will have
an idea similar
to the one I was going to pitch.
-Okay, well, if that happens,
Hannah,
then you would just go ahead
and pitch something else,
because in your time here,
you're gonna pitch
a lot of ideas.
You don't have to get married
to just one. Okay. Andrew.
-Cool. So this is called
New Wikipedia Edits --
Oh, my God!
Wikipedia edits, right there.
Bet you like that idea,
don't you, Seth? You like it.
-Yeah, it's not bad.
-Well, perfect.
Good job, Andrew.
Bad job, Hannah.
Your masturbation pitch
made you look
like a crazy masturbation freak,
even though we all masturbate,
and I can tell you did
probably just this morning.
That's masturbation face.
-Hannah, I think
you're overreacting.
-Well, I'm a little on edge
because I didn't eat breakfast
because I just assumed
there would be free bagels here.
Aren't you predominantly-Jewish
male comedy writers
supposed to be just, like,
stuffing your gross faces
with free bagels constantly?
Just like... [gobbling]
-I'm not Jewish.
-I'm not Jewish or male.
-I'm Jewish and male,
and I would like free bagels.
-Thank you. You and I
will probably have a very
unhealthy workplace romance.
-Okay, you know what?
Let's just move on.
-If you can crack my code.
-Let's move on.
-Back to me then. Cool.
Here's an idea.
Emotionally Disturbed
or Just Hungry?
Seth has a pregnancy scare.
Seth does molly.
Seth sees if he's a little bi.
Jared Leto or Jay Leno?
Seth takes birth control.
Seth lets a woman
or a person of color
host a late night talk show
for the first time ever
because that's never happened,
and it's [bleep] up.
Seth asks a celebrity
interesting questions.
-Okay, well, now, that is
something that I do every night.
-No, I said
interesting questions, Seth.
In-ter-es-ting.
-So how's the first day?
-Honestly, not great.
Everyone's against me.
-Wait, why do you say that?
-I think they're intimidated
by my ideas.
-Yeah, I can see that.
What does Seth
look like without makeup?
-Oh, way older.
-Hannah, it's your turn
to pitch.
-Hold on one second, Seth.
-Hey, wait, wait, wait, wait.
-I have to go.
-I want to talk to you about
how our friendship
has been lately.
-I want to talk about how our
friendship is going lately, too,
because that's what we do,
but I can't right now
because I have this job
and it's really cutting into
our talking about
our friendship time.
Okay. For this last one,
I decided to really go outside
my comfort zone
because I understand
I'm essentially
writing in your voice.
-That sounds like a plan.
-So this sketch is called
"24-Year-Old Seth" and Seth,
you play a 24-year-old girl
living in Brooklyn,
just trying to figure it out,
and then Fred chokes you
during sex.
Okay. I quit.
-You've been here
for less than an hour.
-Yeah.
And I feel like if I stay,
you will continue
to stifle my creativity.
Also, I don't do bits and skits.
I'm more of a long form, voice
of a generation type writer.
-Hannah, before you go,
don't you think it's maybe best
for your overall professional
and personal growth
to stick with this job
instead of leaving
at the first sign of adversity?
-No, that makes zero sense.
Oh, and just to be clear,
this place is stupid.
And honestly, the only reason
I took this job
was because the bagels,
and there are no bagels.
Goodbye.
-I think she's right.
I'll try to get you guys
some bagels.
-All: Yeah!
♪♪
-All right, everybody, it's time
for the weekly pitch meeting.
Let's see what new ideas
you have for the show.
Amber, I'm going
to start with you.
-Okay. This is a bit
where BuzzFeed reports
regular news, like "A Texas Teen
Touched a Downed Power Line,
And What Happens Next
is Shocking."
-Okay, great. Mike, you're up.
-Oh, my God. [ Laughs ]
-What's wrong?
-I thought we were
doing book reports.
-I'm sorry. What?
-Yeah, I swear.
You were like, "Guys,
on Wednesday, we're gonna do
a round of book reports.
Be prepared to share
with the room."
Did anybody else
hear book reports? Ben? Reiss?
-No.
-Are you serious?
-Yeah.
Well, happens to the best of us.
-No, it doesn't.
-Anyways,
"Huckleberry Finn" takes place
in the fictional city
of Saint Petersburg, Missouri.
-Sorry, what are you doing?
-Well, I still did the work.
-We're not going to sit here
and listen to a book report.
-Well, it's a pretty
good one.
-Jenny?
-Okay. This is called.
"Seth Explains Donald Trump
to Kids" --
-Oh, I got a pitch!
-Do you?
-Yes. Yes.
I meant to say I did
a really thorough book report
and a comedy pitch for the show.
-Well, you're standing with
a real book reporting stance,
so already, I'm not filled
with confidence.
-Just let me do this, okay?
So this is a desk piece
and it's like, doo-doo-doo,
cool graphics package.
Like, maybe the band plays
or something like that.
And then you're like,
"I'm Seth Meyers.
It's time for A Closer Look
on Mark Twain."
-Damn it.
-[ Clears throat ]
-Mark Twain was born in 1835,
but his real name
was Samuel Clemens.
-Stop, stop.
-I was trying to shoehorn a
book report into A Closer Look.
Good for you for catching that.
Okay, Real pitch. We invite
Mark Twain on the show.
-Mark Twain is dead.
-[ Gasps ]
Oh, you're right.
-Mike, I never assigned
book reports.
And quite frankly,
if I did, like,
I'm concerned that you chose one
for an eighth grader.
-Concerned your face
is frightening.
-I'm sorry. What was that, Mike?
-Nothing. Geez.
-Goldich, will you
please pitch something?
-I will, but honestly,
I'm not thrilled that
he and I get paid the same.
-That's it.
Okay. Apparently only
the "Voice" chairs do that
and not all NBC shows.
That's good to know.
-What's wrong with you?
-What's wrong with me?!
This is a diarrhea
I made with no help.
Sorry if I'm proud of it.
-Sorry. What did you say?
-I said I was up all night
with this diarrhea,
and I wanted to show it
to my friends.
-That's a diorama.
-What did I say?
-You said you were up
all night with diarrhea,
and you wanted to show it to us.
-Mike! Mike, if you are asleep
right now, just wake up.
Just wake up.
Okay. Apparently this
is really happening.
-Yeah. I don't know
how to address it either.
So, Reiss, can you please
pitch something?
-Are they painting a fence
in that diorama?
-Yes.
-That doesn't happen
in "Huck Finn."
That's from "Tom Sawyer."
-Mike.
After all this,
did you not read the book?
-No, I did not.
-I think you should go.
-Okay. I think that's
for the best. Yeah.
-Okay. Ben, you're up.
-My pitch is for the book
"Catcher in the Rye."
-Oh, all right.
-Nice.
-Well, this kid, he's living
in New York City.
He doesn't know anything.
He doesn't know where he is.
He doesn't know
how he got there. See?
[ Laughter ]
-So, the idea would be
"What's Melania Thinking?"
And we would take,
like, photos of Melania
and we'd put a thought balloon
over her head,
and the joke would be
what she's thinking, like,
"Get me the hell
out of this marriage,"
or, "Even my hands are bigger
than this guy's hands."
You know, stuff like that.
-Yeah, yeah, interesting.
-And it would be repeatable
because there are so many photos
and clips of Melania out there.
-Uh-huh.
-S-So do you want to try it
for rehearsal or...?
-Let me think about it.
-[ Chuckles ]
All right. Come on.
I can't listen to this.
"Let me think about it."
Are you serious?
He's not gonna -- He doesn't
want to think about it.
-Really? 'Cause --
He said it was interesting.
-"Interesting?"
That was a fake interesting.
-What's a fake interesting?
-Fake interesting is this.
Here's a fake interesting.
"Oh. Interesting."
Here's a real interesting.
"Interesting."
-Well, I do have other ideas
that I could pitch.
-I'll bet.
That was your first idea.
I'm sure it was your best.
Right? Please.
You're insulting us here.
-It was my best idea.
Yeah. You're right.
And I do apologize.
-Okay.
Apology accepted.
-[ Scoffs ]
-It comes so easy to you.
-There's nothing to it.
-It's not hard at all?
-No.
-You don't worry
about his feelings?
-Who gives a [bleep]?
-I understand, honey, but the
teacher says he keeps acting out
in class, so we need
to go in and talk to her.
Sorry.
-It's okay.
-Look. I think she's being
unfair to him, too.
-Okay.
-But we have to go in --
-Okay. All right. Okay. Hold on.
Time-out. Time-out.
Not good. This is not good.
-What?
-It's not good.
-What's not good?
-This is a hallway call.
You're making a hallway call
at your desk. Unacceptable.
-Well, I was at the bottom half
of the call, though.
-Oh, were you?
-Yes.
-No. Bull [bleep]. You were
at the top half of the call.
There was a long way
to go in that call.
-How do you know?
How do you know how long -- -
-How do I know? Sounds like
your kid has a lot of problems.
What's he doing in that school?
-That's none of your business.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-Well, you're telling
everybody in the office,
so what do you mean
it's none of my business?
-Well, now --
-You know what?
You're spending too much time
in the office.
You should be home
taking care of your son.
-I have to work.
-You have to work.
And, meanwhile,
what's your son doing?
-He just --
-Beating kids up.
-No, he just threw some food
on the floor.
He didn't beat some kids up.
-Oh, that's --
That's good behav--
Listen. Who you talking to?
Your wife?
-My wife.
-Go in the hall. Go in the hall.
It's enough.
-Fine.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, honey,
I don't know what's going on.
-Yeah, I know what's going on.
You're a terrible father,
and your kid's a maniac.
That's what's going on.
Doesn't take a genius
to figure that out.
Am I right?
-Thank you.
-You're welcome.
-So, yeah, if you could
go down to the salad place
and get me a Greek salad,
feta on the side,
add quinoa
and balsamic vinaigrette,
no olives, and add
the grilled chicken.
-Got it.
-Yeah. Okay.
Uh...
Are you kidding?
-What?
-[ Scoffs ]
That's not a Greek salad.
You call that a Greek salad?
Two substitutions at best.
"Quinoa and chicken and take
this out and take that out."
What are you doing?
-I get this salad all the time.
-You don't get it all the time.
She gets it all the time.
She's the one who has to go and
be humiliated by telling them
all these ridiculous items
that you want.
Right? You don't enjoy
doing that, do you?
-I look like a dick.
-Come on. What is that?
You know what you are?
You're finicky by proxy.
-Finicky by proxy?
-Yes, finicky by proxy.
-What does that mean?
-That means that she's the one
who's the jerk and not you.
You're Mr. White Gloves
sitting in your office
with all your substitutions
waiting for her to come back.
Okay? I want to see you
go down and get it.
I want to see you say the --
you say those substitutions
to that guy, okay?
-Okay. Fine.
-Let's see how you do.
And you know what? Tape it.
-Okay. All right.
-I'd like to see his reaction.
Here's what you're going to get.
"Ugh! Jesus!"
-Okay. Fine. Yeah.
I'll do it myself.
-Okay.
-I'll ask them.
-Okay. Get lost.
-All right. Okay.
-I'll be here. Okay.
-Okay.
-Do you want a coffee
or something?
-You know what?
I think I'm gonna have a bagel.
With cream cheese.
Not too much. Okay?
Tomato thinly sliced.
-Okay.
-A thinly sliced onion.
-I love that.
-Okay?
-Yeah.
-Don't come back
with big chunks of onion.
And maybe a little...
maybe a little, eh, cucumber.
You're not going to
kill anybody.
-Cucumber. That's fun!
-Um, hey, guys.
Uh, Sophie and I would like
to have all of you over
for dinner this Thursday.
You know, about 8:00.
We were thinking, you know,
it'd be nice for everyone
to get together outside of work
and enjoy a nice meal together.
-[ Scoffs ]
Have you lost your mind?
-What?
-"What?" Are you serious?
You're inviting them for dinner?
Nobody wants to go
to your house
after working with you all day.
W-Where did you
get this idea from?
-I'd just thought it'd be fun.
Maybe they want to see
my apartment, you know?
-They want to see
your apartment?
What, is it such a sleek Fifth
Avenue apartment or something?
What's the big deal
with your apartment?
How many bathrooms do you have?
-One and a half.
-What's the half?
-You knows, it's like a --
There's a toilet and a sink.
But there's no tub
for showering.
-Oh. Okay.
-So it's a half.
-Got it.
Do you want to go to his house?
Not really. Speak up. Speak up.
-I don't -- I don't want
to go to your house.
-Yeah. Do you?
Do you want to go to his house?
No. No. Nobody wants
to go to your house.
I'm sorry. They don't.
-No.
-What do you say to that?
Bad idea.
-Yeah.
-"It was a bad idea, Larry."
-I guess it's a bad idea, Larry.
Yeah.
-Yes. Very bad idea.
You know why?
Because you're co-workers.
You're not really friends.
You don't really like
each other.
There's a lot of
competition here.
You know? Everybody
actually hates each other.
They just pretend
to like each other.
Right?
-I-I guess that's the case.
-You probably hate everybody
more than the others.
Because you want to fool them
into thinking you like them more
by inviting them to dinner.
See? They just saw through
the whole charade.
I'm sorry.
-[ Sighs ] Yeah.
I guess you're right.
-So apologize to everybody.
-I-I'm sorry, everyone,
for the charade.
-"I really don't
like you all very much."
-I don't like you all very much.
-Perfect.
-Yeah.
-Perfect! Perfect.
Let's say, "Yeah,
I feel the same way.
I feel the same way."
-Yeah, I feel the same way.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We all feel the same.
-Okay?
-All right.
-Great.
-Okay. Go back to work.
Good.
-Thank you so much
for being here today.
-[ Scoffs ] Come on.
No. It was good. It was fun.
-You had a good time? Fun time?
-Yeah. Fun.
-In that case, when do you think
you might want to come back?
-No, no, no, no, no.
He does not want to come back.
He's here now. He's fulfilling
his obligation as we speak.
-Yeah, but I just thought
if he had a good time....
You know, he could say no if
he doesn't want to come back.
-No, he couldn't.
No one wants to say no directly.
The human race is a cowardly
and indirect people.
Hm? That's where it's at now.
You don't want to look someone
in the face and say, "No."
No one wants
to do an eyeball "No."
You want to do an e-mail "no."
You want to do a text "no."
You want to send your damn
hologram to fill in for you
so you can lie
and make an excuse
without looking
at your sad face.
Your face is very sad right now.
I wish I had
those mirrored sunglasses on
so you could see
the reflection of your face.
Sad. Sadness.
-You know,
I could have said all that.
-Yeah, you could have said it,
but you didn't say [bleep].
-Yeah. I saw you take
those pencils, J.
-Yeah, I thought that desk piece
turned out great, Amber.
So, we got
a very busy day today.
Let's try to run through this
as quickly as possible.
Mike, I'm specifically
talking to you.
Please no interruptions
today, all right?
-Thank you very much.
-So, for guests tonight,
we got Jeff Goldblum.
And then we'll talk
to Dick Cavett.
And, in Act 6, we are going to
do a cooking segment.
-Oh, also, my cousin "Skiz"
is on the show.
-What?
-Yeah.
He's gonna do vape tricks.
Mike, you can't just
book guests on the show
without telling anyone.
-I did tell you.
-I would never have
agreed to that.
-On Monday, I said,
"My cousin Skiz is coming
to the show this week,"
and you said,
"That's awesome, Mike."
And I specifically remember,
because up until then,
you've never said, "This is
awesome, Mike" about anything.
-I thought you meant
he was coming to watch.
-Oh. He wouldn't do that.
He hates this show.
Oh, that reminds me --
no Trump jokes today.
Skiz is a fan.
-Are you serious?
-Well, not of his politics.
He just thinks
he's a good husband.
-You invited a Trump fan on
this show to do vape tricks?
-The man gave me
a kidney, Reiss.
-He did?
-Yeah.
But I didn't even ask for it.
He just showed up one day
with an Igloo cooler
and asked me to stash it.
-How do you
get to work every day?
Does an adult drop you off?
-No, a child drives me.
I'm sorry.
Did that sound sarcastic?
I meant, no.
A child drives me.
-Well, Mike, we can't have
a four guests on the show.
I'm sorry.
-Well, then one of us is gonna
have to deliver the bad news.
-You! You're the only one
who knows him.
-I don't know Jeff Goldblum.
-We're not bumping
Jeff Goldblum.
-Aww! Poor Dick Cavett.
-I have a question.
-Yes, Skiz is circumcised.
-That is not even in
the ballpark of my question.
What vape tricks does
this boy actually know?
-Currently, none, but he said
he would learn some by tonight.
-He doesn't even know
any vape tricks?
-Uh, neither does Jeff Goldblum,
and you still booked him.
God, what is his problem today?
-When I first met you,
I assumed this was
some sort of Batkid scenario,
but it's been a few years now,
and you're still here.
-Okay. I know I don't
speak up much here.
-Oh, my God.
It's literally
the only thing you do here.
-But I'm feeling
very attacked right now,
when I did absolutely
nothing wrong.
-You booked your cousin
on the show
without telling anyone to
perform a skill he doesn't have.
[ Knock on door ]
-Hey, I'm looking for the
dressing room and also ecstasy.
-You must be Skiz.
-No.
I work for Dick Cavett.
And, for the record,
he prefers powder to pills.
-That's very cool.
-Well, tell Dick Cavett
we don't have any of that stuff.
-Wow. Okay.
He's going to freak.
-I accept your apology.
-Get out of here.
♪♪